this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up everybody michael here to talk
about the world's leading advocate
against amphibians sexual agency i don't
like them putting chemicals in the water
that turn the friggin frogs gay
alexander emrick jones there have been
better times to be mr jones's wallet
actually has there ever been a good time
to be inside the pants of alex jones
regularly i don't think so last month he
was ordered to pay over 49 million
dollars in a defamation lawsuit brought
by the parents of the children killed in
the sandy hook massacre indeed thanks
largely to jones influence a staggering
one in five americans thinks sandy hook
was staged but even if you aren't among
the nearly 20 of americans convinced
that grieving parents are actually well
paid actors
chances are you've stumbled upon your
fair share of misinformation on the
internet this leaves us wondering
why is contemporary discourse so filled
with misinformation what's more are
these falsehoods threatening the very
fabric of our society and do shared
societal truths even exist anymore let's
investigate in this wisecrack edition is
misinformation here to stay so what is
misinformation anyway well as defined by
the cuny graduate school of journalism
it's the sharing of inaccurate and
misleading information in an
unintentional way it's often accompanied
by its more villainous sibling
disinformation which is misinformation
spread with the intention to deceive
typically to further political goals now
miss and disinformation have been around
since the first neanderthal took false
credit for inventing fire but
misinformation needs widespread mediums
of communication to really spread take
ancient rome where coins were basically
the first mass-produced methods of
communication regularly used to project
rulers power and convey state propaganda
it didn't take long for julius caesar's
adopted son octavian to use engraved
coins to spread disinformation about his
rival mark anthony calling him among
other things a raging alcoholic and a
traitor for marrying cleopatra skip
ahead to the invention of the printing
press which significantly lowered the
barrier to circulate your ideas there
were political ramifications to this
like when rebels trying to take down
england's king george ii filled papers
with fake stories claiming that he was
ill king george ultimately prevailed but
the rebels kick started a solid game of
political health shaming that unlike
king george remains alive and well today
as for america it's been awash with
misinformation since the colonial days
when posters and pamphlets propagated
biased politicized news benjamin
franklin himself amplified revolutionary
fervor by penning propaganda stories
about indigenous americans colluding
with king george iii i don't know much
for sure but i know that if your name is
king george people probably hate you
when american newspapers emerged in the
early 1800s they balanced hard news with
straight-up fake stories like the great
moon hoax in which the new york sun
claimed there was an alien colony on the
moon by the 1890s what we now call
yellow journalism erupted as newspaper
magnates joseph pulitzer and william
randolph hearst battled in a circulation
war using misleading and fantastical
headlines to sell papers think of it as
um early clickbait except they weren't
clicking they were they were grabbing
papers so we'll call it grab bait the
influence of yellow journalism is often
cited as one of the driving forces of
the spanish-american war so yes some
guys that know newspapers
helped start a war sounds sounds fun
unsurprisingly this is around when the
term fake news seems to have entered the
lexicon if it sounds like early america
was awash in bull news
it's because it totally was but as
philosopher jacob saul writes yellow
journalism had a backlash effect as
people sought out more objective or
reputable news newspapers started hiring
better educated reporters and
journalists to cover fact-based news
about business and the economy for the
wealthy investor class papers started
relying on the subscription model which
further disincentivized disinformation
because customers could simply switch to
a competitor's paper if they felt they
were being duped so again the free
market fixes everything all of this
created an entirely novel media climate
as historian jonathan lab writes the
existence of an independent powerful
widely respected news media
establishment is an historical anomaly
prior to the 20th century such an
institution had never existed in
american history the government also
played a big role in this by 1937 a
roper poll asking is the press fair
showed that 66 percent of americans said
yes continuing this trend in 1949 after
television entered the picture the
federal communications commission sought
to preserve objective news with the
fairness doctrine which required
broadcast news to present balanced
coverage and to supplement controversial
opinions with counterpoints when the
policy was axed by ronald reagan's fcc
in 1987
everything changed wow ronald reagan
ruined something in the 80s this is
crazy according to the washington post
almost overnight the media landscape was
transformed opinionated news including
talk radio shows like rush limbaugh's
exploded on the scene this is also a
benevolent dictatorship i am the
dictator there is no first amendment
here except for me
we have one responsibility and that is
to have the listeners of this show enjoy
it and be entertained and drawn to it
and want to stay at the same time
newsroom shrink and the 24-hour news
cycle emerged the need to produce
greater quantities of news at a faster
pace according to scholar david a logan
incentivized journalists to get the news
first and fast rather than first and
right misinformation unsurprisingly
followed for example in 1985 the soviet
union started a rumor that aids had been
created in a u.s military laboratory
this spread like wildfire and by 1987
reporter dan rather repeated the
accusations on cbs without asking the
government for a response by the time
the internet rolled around all bets were
off if the printing press lowered the
barrier to spread information the
internet obliterated it but the digital
web of misinformation was far less
mainstream as scholar dave carp writes
conspiratorial websites in the mid-1990s
also had a sharply limited audience this
was the pre-google internet where search
was time-consuming and difficult if you
wanted to find information about all
manner of clinton conspiracies in 1997
you would have had to look pretty hard
that was about to change thanks to a
little thing formerly known as the
facebook drop the the just facebook
but before we get into it i want to talk
to you about this video's sponsor keeps
now you might have heard the alarming
statistic that two out of three men will
experience male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 and while that's totally
wild you don't need to worry because you
got keeps now keeps is a subscription
service that makes it easier and more
affordable to prevent hair loss you
start with a free consultation with a
licensed keeps doctor who will help you
get the right combination of fda
approved prescriptions and
over-the-counter medications and you'll
never have to worry about running out of
your keeps products thanks to an
automatic refill that arrives at your
door every three months now if you have
any questions or if you want to share
progress updates you can message your
keeps doctor 24 7. results appear within
four to 12 months so get started today
to hang on to the hair you have join the
hundreds of thousands of men who've
tried keeps and given it more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com wisecrack or
click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash wisecrack now
back to the show while there's a long
history of misinformation in america
things are definitely different today
its reach has been exacerbated by
changes in how the internet and
especially social media spread
information some of this has to do with
the way traditional news pivoted online
where the metric of the page view was
king in the years since things like
social media shares and engagement have
become another important way of
measuring digital success as data
scientist noah giancerakuza writes
contemporary pageview-driven news is the
regrettable 19th century yellow press on
digital steroids with competition for
attention more intense than ever and
advertising revenue and subscription
numbers down even legacy media outlets
have started relying more on heavily
charged emotions and extreme opinions
this is exemplified by someone like
tucker carlson who fended off a slander
lawsuit in 2020 when a judge ruled that
viewers should already know that he's
not stating actual facts and is
presenting non-literal commentary m m's
will not be satisfied until every last
cartoon character is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous until the moment
you wouldn't want to have a drink with
any one of them that's the goal when
you're totally turned off
we've achieved equity they've won
you and me both tucker this shift has
also changed the way we view the
obligations of reporters as scholar
norman fairclough explains in addition
to the knowledgeable reporter informing
the interested citizen there is an
element of the media artist entertaining
the viewer as consumer across mediums
this has led to the rise of infotainment
or news presented with all the trappings
of conventional entertainment formats or
entertainment presented with all the
traffics of the news format i'm here at
the pentagon to find out what space
force the sixth and coolest branch of
the u.s military does i'm talking
spaceships lasers it's the military in
space
it's worth noting that news hasn't
always been about the hustle to make
money mark gunther notes that as
recently as the late 1970s there was no
network news business the big three
broadcast television networks all
covered news but none generally made
money doing so nor did they expect to
turn a profit from news program in
contrast as scholar jason harson notes
internet news rapidly became a
money-making venture writing the digital
communication infrastructure is not
designed to suit democratic political
communication or trustworthy information
but rather to suit recent forms of
consumer capitalism the attention
economy as we've become habituated to
perpetually shocking headlines
disinformation has flourished carp says
to state it plainly fake news in the
1990s was a hobby today it is an
industry for that matter it's an
industry worth nearly a quarter billion
dollars in online ad revenue annually as
of 2019. almost 40 percent of that
revenue came from google algorithmically
primed to boost content that incites our
most extreme emotions social media has
been crucial to the spread of
misinformation we talked about this in a
recent video but it's worth repeating
controversial ideas equate to virality
on social media as journalists stuart a
thompson and charlie warzell write
facebook's algorithms have coaxed many
people into sharing more extreme views
on the platform rewarding them with
likes and shares for posts on subjects
like election fraud conspiracies coveted
19 denialism and anti-vaccination
rhetoric in recent years such stories
have been amplified by bot farms and
meme accounts which efficiently churn
out misinformation in the form of
recognizable visual jokes and catchy
slogans importantly memes are extremely
hard to moderate or if you're a member
of gen x extremely hard to understand
so even when social media platforms
attempt to weed out disinformation
images of obama as a lizard person can
skirt by undetected but while it's easy
to blame misinformation on the evolved
media landscape we think there's
something more going on harsen argues
that we live in a cultural ambiance of
post-truth defined by a breakdown of
social trust parson blames the
mainstreaming of this public anxiety
about truth on the influence and
persuasion industries like pr marketing
and political communications he writes
that they went from appealing to
people's reason to strategically
managing their emotions and attention
via organized systematic lying such
lying is now seen as banal unremarkable
even expected in commercials or
political speech parson argues that
increasingly journalism and opinionated
commentary use the same emotional
appeals of politicians and advertisers
as a result people tend to measure
believability and what makes them feel
the most and outrageous disinformation
can make us feel
a lot it's fitting that alex jones's
reporting style is defined by his pathos
frequently expressed an angry and
passionate outburst in the absence of
evidence the proof lies in his emotional
appeals.com
you're watching the sunday positions
we have an idiot on the program today
he will not stop the republic humanity
is awakening carson argues that these
exaggerated claims made in the pursuit
of profit have fundamentally altered our
world views he quotes theorist allison
hearns who writes promotionalism names
the extension of market values and
commodity relations in all areas of life
in a population so acclimatized to the
constant cell
how can we recognize or construct
legitimate authority the link between
the language used in advertising and the
language used to spread disinformation
becomes all the more apparent when we
look at the way alex jones uses the same
platforms to propagate political rumors
and to sell dubious products like super
male vitality supplements which i
definitely didn't take and which
definitely didn't give me a second penis
that knew all the words to every kid
rock song that's how we fund this
revolution against the new world order
in short our culture is saturated in
[ __ ] and we're used to being lied to
by basically everyone at all times it's
a fun way to live right feeling like we
can't trust anything that everyone's
lying to us um you can trust me though
maybe as harsen argues american
democracy has been among other things an
evolving competition of fakery it could
be said that people would be irrational
not to be highly skeptical of truth
claims and skeptical they are gallup
polls have found that in 1997 53 of
respondents said they trusted mass media
reporting to portray the news fully
accurately and fairly by 2021 just 29 of
americans said they have a fair amount
of trust for the news and as journalist
tom dowell writes when people cease to
trust the authorities they some of them
anyway become at once more skeptical and
more credulous and fake news is all too
ready to slide into the credulous folks
dms thus it's never been easier to fall
for something that isn't true and this
played out especially painfully during
the 2016 presidential election a story
about the pope endorsing trump for
instance ricocheted across facebook with
nearly a million engagements to bring it
before voters eyes and disappointed
voters found their own solace in a story
that got nearly as many engagements
post-election that ireland would take in
american refugees which you know isn't
true because i'm not broadcasting live
from galway bay it's why up to 40
percent of americans don't believe the
results of the last presidential
election and it's why a pew research
poll in the summer of 2020 found that
largely thanks to traction gained on
twitter and elsewhere online 71 percent
of americans had heard the conspiracy
theory that coveted was planned by
governments possibly in hopes of
injecting citizens with microchips to be
tracked on 5g networks and a third of
those people believed the theory if
you're looking for an online community
where people won't convince you that you
have 5g in your body you should jump on
wisecrack's discord which is a perk you
get by joining our patreon where not
only to get our discord server you get
the videos early and without ads you
have access to extra philosophy office
hours with me extra podcast content
check it out we got a lot of stuff going
on and i promise we will not try to
conspiracy theory you much so where does
all of this leave us as stanford scholar
renee destro explains we are living in
an epistemological takedown wherein
people think facts don't exist anymore
and that feels like a pretty daunting
problem to have but this isn't the first
time humans have grappled with concerns
about the extinction of truth a key
question asked by some of the
philosophers associated with
post-modernism was whether or not truth
was still a useful category now this is
in contrast to ancient philosophers like
plato and aristotle and some more modern
idealists like content hegel who in
their own ways all believed that human
reason could arrive at some
understanding of universal truths and
concepts but for philosophers like
jacques derrida and emmanuel levinos who
drew inspiration from 19th century
thinkers like nietzsche and kierkegaard
classically metaphysical models of truth
sort of flatten the realities of actual
human existence and often favor a more
theological or hierarchical way of
thinking now according to philosopher
jean-francois leotard post-modernism is
defined by an incredulity towards
metanarratives now in other words
postmodernism is a sensibility which is
skeptical of metaphysical or scientific
modes of thinking which claim to explain
everything in one consistent system i.e
that all existence is oriented towards
one cosmic omnipotent being or concept
now derrida thought that instead of some
universal hierarchical truth meaning has
more to do with close readings that
reckon with a fundamental difference or
undecidability in all texts and
situations for some this seems like an
admittance that truth doesn't exist and
everything is ultimately subjective well
for others this is a position of
epistemic humility now for darida this
meant that the notions of truth that
underlied various colonial political
projects were no longer to be taken as
universally valid which too many would
be very very good but for others making
truth supposedly subjective could have
the cultural effect of creating a
free-for-all in which all ideas of truth
and justice are equally valid and
philosophers like elon bed jew have
noted how this free-market approach to
truth has been a wonderful gift for
capitalism as it takes traditional
categories of truth like art love
science and turns them into things that
can be more easily marketed bought or
sold so art becomes culture love becomes
sex science becomes technology for
example scientific innovation and
discovery used to be motivated by a
desire to better understand ourselves
and the cosmos but technology became
about using science to build fancy
gizmos that make stockholders happy and
while love was once about authentic
romantic connection now dating apps and
websites call our data while teaching us
to reduce the complexity of love and
sexuality to a few doctored images on
our phones and mine i have lots of hair
things that once gave meaning to our
lives now become mere products for baju
the reintroduction of truth is necessary
to combat this but rather than the
singular truth of plato or religion he
argues for truths which are relative to
specific situations and these truths are
what can give meaning to our lives
outside of the free market whether that
truth is a lover a commitment to art a
passion for science or a desire for
justice and in case you're thinking yeah
but what if my truth is fascism badu
argues that the thing that all truths
have in common is the principle of
equality so i guess your fascist streams
will have to remain just that but in the
absence of such high-minded ideals we're
left in the truthless ruins that
postmodern capitalism has wrought and
that makes it really easy for
misinformation to infiltrate the
discourse which is one thing if you
decide to become a quirky flat earther
but another when you start pizzagating
with a side of doxing but what do you
all think is our society too fractured
to agree upon anything ever again or can
we regain even a modicum of reverence
for truth and objectivity to save
ourselves let us know in the comments
and if you haven't checked it out yet
please come hang out with us at our new
stream wisecrack live it happens right
here every thursday at 11am pacific
thanks to our patrons as always and
please please like this video if you
found that it gave you real information
as always thanks for watching i'll catch
you later
[Music]
you